معركه شرق اوكرانيا تشتد بين قوات كيف
وموسكو واوكرانيا تجد نفسها تتوسلوا الى
الدول الغربيه بغيه تزويدها باسلحه ثقيله
لدعم استعاده اراضيها
اوكرانيا تقول انها بحاجه الى 300 دبابه
غربيه حديثه خلال الربيع القادم
لاستخدامها في المناطق التي استولى الروس
عليها منذ بدايه الحرب فبعد عام تقريبا
منذ بدء لعمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا تراجع عدد الدبابات التي
يستخدمها الجيش الاوكراني في معركه بسبب
خساره العديد منها في المعارك وخروج
العديد منها من الخدمه بسبب انعدام قطع
الغيار الضروريه
الدبابات الاوكرانيه التي تعود الى مرحله
الستينات والسبعينات من القرن الماضي
تعاني العديد من الاعطال والمشاكل لسوء
الصيانه والاهمال قبل الحرب هذا عدا عن ان
غالبا ما تجري الصيانه في ورش متخصصه
بعيده عن خطوط القتال قبل اندلاع الحرب
كانت اوكرانيا تملكون احواها 900 دبابه من
طرازات المرحله السوفياتيه مثل 72
64 وخلال فتره حل في بور تبرعت لها بعد
دول الكتله الشرقيه السابقه التي انضمت
الى حلف الناتو بحوالي 200 دبابه من طراز
تي 72 وتعتبر بريطانيا هي اول دوله تتبرع
لاوكرانيا بدبابات قتاليه حيث منحت 14
دبابه من طراز شالنجر 2 الاوكرانيا وفقا
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني بنواس
ورغم ان هذه الدبابات فعاله في ساحه
المعركه لكنها قد تمثل عبء ان لوجيا على
اوكرانيا لقله عددها واستخدامها لذخائر
خاصه بها لا تتطابق مع مواصفات ذخائر حلف
الناتو او ذخائر الدبابات الروسيه التي
تملكها اوكرانيا الشخصيات العربيه